Alibaba`s mission is to make it easy to do business anywhere.
Alibaba's Xianyu has 200 million registered users,
over 50 million of whom are using Flutter.
Xianyu's goal is to ensure that the value
of idle resources is maximized
creating a new lifestyle for the younger generation.
For example, when a vendor wants to sell
their collection of accessories for pets,
they should be able to post a well-designed
ad as quickly as possible.
And when a customer wants to buy something for their pet,
all they need is a swipe on the app.
We asked ourselves how can we create apps
that are easy to navigate for our users.
How can we ensure that our apps have beautiful graphics
and still load fast?
How can we make our apps accessible
to as many users as possible?
And more importantly, how can we do all of this fast?
So we started looking for a solutionand came across
Flutter by Google.
We were immediately intrigued by Flutter's user
experience including high FPS and smooth UI.
But above all, it was an incredible time-saver.
All developers know that in order to reach the biggest
amount of users,
you need to build apps for iOS and Android,
maintaining two codebases,
which will slow you down.
Flutter, however, allows us to use a single codebase,
which makes maintenance of our apps so much better.
It sounded like Flutter was a perfect fit, so we gave it a go.
We started implementing Flutter features incrementally,
incorporating them with our apps.
The ItemDetail page, the most important, complex and
frequently visited section,
is run through a single codebase on
Android and iOS using Flutter.
During the last months, Flutter has helped us tremendously.
It is super fast because it is a fully native app.
The expressive UI widgets allow us to make sleek UI.
Finally, it significantly reduces the workload
when we implement new features.
Now we are highly efficient when it comes to
designing iOS and Android apps.
The ItemPost page, a cornerstone of Xianyu's app,
was also developed through Flutter.
We are excited to build many more features using Flutter
to move Alibaba's Xianyu forward.